this is our starship in a caravan  simulator  take some simulation flight and weapons  training but it will goes horribly  horribly wrong there in the aspects  there about affordable to planet by  axiom and I repair helicopter usually a  fire burn up in the atmosphere  jolly Lister this about two and a half  months to build which we started with a  caravan stripped out the inside and put  in a load of computers Tech and pretty  much anything we had lying around our  hack space and you end up with a pretty  good simulating so far pretty much  everyone loves it even though success  rate on it is a bit low  yeah we die I Jam signal  I go wrong so it awarded us an excuse we  take a list to pretty much every Mini  Maker Faire around the UK tech  conferences and maybe a street near you